hey youtubers is Charlie so Zack Snyder
dropped this Batman bomb on us today
just by surprise it's Batman's new
tactical suit that he's going to be
wearing during Justice League so let's
break it down what you're looking at
right here is Batman's tactical suit
upgrade so it's a version of the cloth
suit with plates built on top of it in
the style of his battle suit that he was
fighting Superman in that is much less
mobile than this
so it's a suit for fighting parademons
but also provides some of the level of
protection that his battle suit does
wearing that suit is like walking around
in a tank
I remember when Zack Snyder was first
describing it he said that it's not so
much a suit to help him defeat Superman
it's a way to just buy a couple extra
seconds before Superman crumples him
like a soda can
so now as with previous Batman films
like they kind of did the same thing
with the Christian Bale Batman films
where like the first version of the bat
suit was a little more bulky than he
wanted to move his head around so he had
to give up some of the protection
offered by that big suit for the
modularity of the lighter suit but still
it ended up being worth it so fighting
parademons obviously this is going to be
way more hardcore than previous versions
of any Christian Bale suit but the other
obvious reference is that yes it does
look very much inspired by The Owl Man
costume the second Dalaman costume from
Watchmen so even though that might seem
weird you just have to remember that all
directors borrow from their previous
work even steven spielberg I mean Steven
Spielberg is a really old man now he's
made a lot of films of course she's
going to be borrowing visual elements
from previous films but it is kind of
nice now that we know that because of
rebirth in the comics Watchmen is now
part of the main DC Universe if you
don't know anything about rebirth in the
comics don't worry it's not going on in
the film's Watchmen is still like a
completely separate universe in the
movies and also the Watchmen story is
intended to criticize superheroes like
the whole genre of superheroes Justice
League is more intended to celebrate
that now I've talked about some of the
other big changes they made with the
film so I'll put a link in the
description for that stuff Geoff Johns
has said a lot about the cool stuff that
they've done to change Justice League in
light of the reaction to Batman V
Superman but let's focus more on what's
going on here so the other big
that might not be evident is that he's
standing inside a hangar next to the
upgraded Batmobile
so the Batmobile itself is still the
same basic car but it also has been
upgraded with more armor more weapons
remember fighting parademons need some
better toys and it's not really evident
from this wall here but there they're
basically inside Batman's floating
fortress he has a plane that he's turned
into like a mobile Batcave that they're
going to be using in the film I don't
know if they've accelerated Superman's
return in the movie but for most of the
movie Batman is their source of funding
he's the guy that collects them all that
brings them together so naturally he'd
have to have a way to get around quickly
that is the floating Batcave which we
don't know what the actual look of it is
going to be but it's probably just gonna
be a heavily modified military jet just
big enough to house the Batmobile on any
other gear that they might need so let
me know what you guys think of the
costume it does look a lot sleeker so
it's definitely more functional I don't
know if I like the ears so much and I'm
not super hot on the goggles but
otherwise like the plating the look of
it it looks pretty badass so I would
expect to get like a really good look at
this to see it in action in the first
real trailer that they drop there is a
rumor that we're gonna get the first
real Justice League trailer around
Christmas so I think that's a pretty
safe bet because that'd be about six
months out from when this movie's gonna
drop I don't know how gratuitous they're
gonna get with Batman Batsuit money
shots in the Batcave because he has so
many different suits each designed to
serve a different purpose
I'm hoping we eventually get to see like
a hell bat but I really want like an
Iron Man scene where he's like looking
at all the different armors just teasing
you with all the different versions of
the suit that he has like when they went
from the first Avengers film to Iron Man
3 Iron Man 3 was like the next big film
after Avengers so it followed up on some
of the plot points Iron Man naturally
paranoid after his experience going
through the wormhole just built all
kinds of different suits he built the
iron Legion then proceeded to blow it up
by the end of the movie which was kind
of sucky but I just like the idea that
Batman's had this vision so he has this
Tony Stark moment where he just can't
sleep at night so he goes way overboard
armoring up and helps the Justice League
armor up too they haven't
illicitly explained where the flash got
all the parts to make his suit right
here but is a safe bet that billionaire
Bruce Wayne with Wayne tech will help
him modify it just a little bit like
Wonder Woman Aquaman they don't need a
lot of help like Aquaman where's
Atlantean armor is probably just as
strong as Kryptonian armor so the only
thing the Batman could really do to help
out in that situation would be to like
buff out all the scratches but let me
know what you guys think Batman
upgrading all of his tech do you think
he's going to help all the rest of the
Justice League upgrade their stuff too
but just a heads up if you guys didn't
know YouTube rolled out a whole bunch of
updates most of the bugs have been fixed
but every time they roll out a big
change there's some weird bugs so if the
comments look different if something
seems just a little bit off it's because
they enabled a couple new features so
like the links that I put at the end of
my videos you can click on those if
you're watching this on your phone now
whereas you could not before there's a
couple other new features that they
haven't rolled out yet so I'll do a
video like once those are all out I'll
do a video explaining what's different
but I will say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner ray prints you
win an Amazon gift card for the flash
season 2 blu-ray be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so
there is a new round that starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
the giveaway will still be going until
the flash premieres in a couple weeks so
Zack Snyder dropping this teaser on us
was a bit of a surprise so my next video
will be like the punisher season 1 video
that i was planning on making before
this happened so that'll be up early on
Thursday so get hype well you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
watch the Justice League trailer again
and you can click here to learn all
about the flash season 3 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight